now let's talk first of all if we may
about Simon and Clark former Minister
yesterday saying that nurses on 35
000 pounds a year who rely on food banks
are not managing their finances properly
what would you say
well
um I would suggest to Simon Clark that
he would be better working with his
party to try and find a resolution to
the the strikes that are happening now
and and resolve the issues for the
brilliant nurses that we see behind us
this morning I think it's just another
another move to show the disdain and
disrespect that this government's
showing to to the brilliant nurses that
you see standing behind me this morning
pushed out onto picket lines instead
have been in the hospitals and in their
workplaces looking after their patients
what's your reaction to the health
secretary Steve Barclays comments
yesterday saying a pay rise for nurses
would cost lives
well
um I think what Steve Barkley fails to
understand is that a looking after
patients
um and the money that's that's needed
for for that is the same as two sides of
the same coin that care and treatments
provided by the nursing staff that you
see on the picket lines this morning so
separating the market out like that is
disingenuous as far as we're concerned
Steve Barkley also says that there's
only three months left on this uh
Financial year
um is it not worth engaging in next
year's pay round rather than
concentrating on these a few months
three months up to April when it looks
as other government are not going to
give you any more money
look our dispute is is in relation to
22-23
um let's stop pushing the can further
and further down the road again that's
that's disrespectful to our nursing
staff over 300 000 that participated in
this ballot give us the strongest
mandate as a Royal College of Nursing
and so let's deal with the here and I
let's resolve the issues in relation to
the nurses pay for 20 to 23 and then
let's get in to Serious discussions
serious discussions about 23 24 but we
need to resolve 22 23.
are you not going to find yourself in a
position come April where you still
haven't resolved the pay dispute for
this year and yet you're going to have
to start negotiating next year where's
that going to leave you
well we can negotiate for 22 23 and 23
24 but the fact of the matter is this
government has not started negotiations
and any ship form or fashion with me as
the general secretary for these nurses
so I don't know when they are going to
start negotiating for 23-24 when they
haven't even commenced negotiations for
22-23 so the ball is in their Court
we've said time and time again the olive
branch has been fairly extended to them
Let's Get Right a table and negotiate I
can't negotiate at a table on my own I
certainly will not disrespect the nurses
that I'm walking amongst today and by
negotiating on the airwaves and I think
this government owes it to every single
nurse and a member of our nursing staff
to get around the table with me very
very quickly and because it's very very
concerning that they are allowing these
strikes to continue and further strikes
a plan for the beginning of February why
are you striking with ambulance workers
and also with 999 call handlers on the
6th of February when you've previously
said that you object to coordinated
strike action
actually I learned about the GMB
decision after you yesterday we have not
coordinated strikes but inevitably as
long as this government continues to
allow the industrial action to to to to
to to to continue and not get right
negotiating tables of course they're
there will be overlap but my concern my
hundred percent concentration is on the
nurses and nursing staff that you see
behind me and on every picket line line
today that's what I need to get resolved
for the for for those people so they can
get back into their work continue to
look after their patients so it is about
Rishi sunak needing to address those
issues I'm not allowing those debts to
continue by getting right on a
negotiating table negotiating with
myself and of course with those
ambulance workers who also deserve Fair
pay
yeah but maybe not coordinated but you
could always postpone your strike or
move it to another day you had said
previously that you were not in favor of
um NHS unions all going out on strike at
the same time
I've just answered that question and
said I learned about it after
um you yesterday
nor has the Royal nor has the Royal
College of Nursing today my
concentration is walking amongst the
brilliant members that you see standing
out here and thanking them for
continuing to work in the most
challenging of circumstances continuing
to look after their passions in an NHS
that's in crisis that's what I'll
concentrate on today and then tomorrow
I'll get back to business to planning
and where we go in the future but Pat
you could move the date couldn't you
I I really do think okay I've answered
that question I don't think you have
which is why I'm asking you
no I think I have I said that I learned
about the debt after a year yesterday in
fact I learned I learned about it
through the media we have not
coordinated
where's the GMB we've not coordinated
with strikes with the gym business and
I'm sure you can imagine that my
concentration yesterday and today is to
be amongst our members and making sure
that we continue as we always have
throughout this period of industrial
action to provide safe industrial action
making sure that that we provide life
preserving Services continue to provide
emergency care and then tomorrow I will
be back at my office desk working with
my clinical staff about where we move to
next 6th of February
nurses will strike ambulance workers
will strike at 999 call handlers will
strike people will die who is
responsible
look the unfortunate thing is and I know
this as a nurse myself and we heard it
from the Royal College of emergency
medicine and patients are dying
unnecessarily
um on a daily basis as a consequence of
the crisis that we've got within the
Health Service what our nursing staff
are trying to do is trying to bring the
NHS back from this crisis we are trying
to recruit nurses into the profession
we're trying to hold on to the nurses
that you see standing outside in the
cold this morning and we will only do
that by treating them decently getting
around a negotiating table try and
resolve the issues in 22-23 and then
let's move on from there
but who will be responsible if if
unnecessary lives our lives are lost
unnecessarily on the 6th of February
because of strike action by ambulance
workers call workers and nurses well you
see
you see I'm I'm I'm interested in that
question being asked to me because how
many times has government been a
government been asked about lives that
have been lost as a consequence
our health service but we hear our
account services every single solitary
day every single day so um please not do
not place this on our nursing staff the
nursing staff that have stood up so
courageously and so determined to say
enough is enough the Health Services in
crisis if you do not address the crisis
in nursing we will never address the
crisis within the NHS so I think um it
is disrespectful to actually push more
responsibility and more guilt onto the
ferry people that's standing out today
losing another day's pay on behalf of
their patients to make sure that our
patients are cared for as we move
forward